今日は畑はいというわけでみなさん歌カラオケとが歌いますが結構儲かろう穴がみんな
楽しいれるものだと思うんですけども歌には勝つというものがありますかシーっていう
ものにはまあ曲に込められたメッセージとも意味合いとか伝えたいこととか
あの歌手には分なぁ意味が込められていると思うんですけどもまぁ
[音楽]
クリエイティビティなんですよ
あの音楽を聴いただけでもその曲の意味を構図分の中で理解して飲み込んで僕のさんが
曲でもう歌詞を当てれるんじゃないかってなんで今回は2人捨てて俺だけがすらない曲
をちょっともうちょいサウンドから見つけてもらって僕一回聞くんで
僕なりにちょっと解釈して活動をつけます作った加瀬があってたらもうその音楽だけで
飯月
4組とって言ってました逆にすごくねすごいと思う
逆じゃなくすごいですよね奥田その今日は労働制というか
独創性音楽を聞くだけでメッセージ性を自分の中で解釈できる力をちょっと皆さんに
見せようと思います
いつも ok です ok 通すリアからないってなるとも結構マニアックになっ
ちゃいますよねいけたんじゃ
ですかジョコビッチもこれいってますか1回引いていいとりあえず
これなんかそうそうでしょう
違うあれだけ言うとなさそうそうですよ
あの薄紅色の嘘
[音楽]
を押すだけんですよじゃあ豊富かのチェーンなどある意味で消すって
一青窈さ一青窈でしょね色
[音楽]
[拍手]
わかんないはウソはなんだよ感ない俺は絶対知ってると思いました頃後これ絶対知っ
てると思うんですか悲壮な曲ではあるんじゃねタブー
後ろないものペットグッズジャンル的に知らない筈の無いよな
あけますっがんばっえっにょ教科書見てるにょ
持っています
[拍手]
[音楽]
立ち上がれ俺ベティ
歌え
諦めろそう情熱よってよろしい衛兵
さらなるイェーイへ
くっ
[音楽]
male 家に帰ることを釣りい
ねええええ諦めずう
ana ばいいなあこの大丈夫ねぇ
car
他ならぬテコ入れ像桜登り滑る誤差
nome asuta
どんな敵魔王僕らへんがコップし face 突然フェスや
どうでしたかすりもしなかったんだって化しないところで歌って歌手あるところでやっ
ほ
[音楽]
わかんないわはい持つくださいとかなというではならしますはいお願います無理やそう
だったんじゃないのっ
[音楽]
小歩危 a ギスえーい
ana れどうすでー
これを通すで俺んっ
po せて彼ばっかり eno デー
ani came
ana
くるから
na na na na
[拍手]
あかぬない目指しデー
anus rhus じゃあ
re
ani
さ殴り合いでしたよああ
はぁいけそうな気がするタブンネ知らないんじゃないかな怖い
ああ
ございます
ゆうですね
医療する
うんはいはーい
はぁんっ
葛まくってみんな準備が出来ましたけぇ
伐採おまえのパパビっている
ni と目立つロー
濡れちゃったよねー
たえっ
大変がみんな十分は ok
ブーブーまつりだパダ多いで多いねぇみんなで多いで私もらいふんっは
me
まだん
ガーナ得るまで帰ります a
はいはいまた数杯を外し新しい
はぁはぁぁ
[音楽]
me
teame
うううう
me
re だった